hey everybody is Peter Brown here with
Randolph Ramsey and what you're looking
at is ABS Oh from giant squid this is a
Playstation 4 and PC game coming out
next year and it is being helmed by the
creative director for giant squid who is
the art director on journey and Randy am
i accurate in saying this game is a
pretty magical experience it is and you
know it's good that you mentioned
journey because it's it's a very
exponential game in in the same way that
you know journey and some of that game
company stuff is so you know what you're
looking at now basically is the game
you're you're swimming around the ocean
you're you're interacting with wildlife
it doesn't sound super exciting as like
as I'm saying it right now but there's
you know there's a sense of sort of like
Wonder and joy and even when I say it
then it doesn't seem that appealing but
it's great like how did you find it in
your short time with it Peter well I
thought it was like a you know it's not
a stimulator right it's really not even
though they are saying that you know
there's a lot of real wildlife in here
they're mimicking those behaviors but I
think that does a good job of drawing
you into the world but what really kept
me engaged was the sense of discovery
and the mystery of what lay ahead
because as you can see you know kind of
like when you're in the ocean you can't
see very far and like journey you know
you get a little beacon that you know in
the distance maybe it's movement or
light and that really draws your eye in
and draws you to go explore and see
what's out there
yeah and speaking the sense of discovery
I mean we're just looking at this little
yellow robot here and you know in the in
the short demo that we play there were a
few of these you could actually find if
you exploit enough I only managed to
find one but yeah it was that you know
it was that sense of you know having to
explore the spaces that we were in and
moving around quite a lot I mean when
you first start the game you you
starting off in quite shallow waters so
you know you you go around you try and
swim with some fish you eventually find
that hey there's this little passageway
here that actually goes a little bit
deeper you go in there you find all new
species of fish you could interact with
them in different ways this turtle for
example I love turtle riding when I play
this and and apparently there is a I
don't want to say narrative but there is
like a through line to this game right
in which there is an endpoint that you
can reach
that you know basically I guess ends
your experience with an absurd I suppose
yeah and you know playing with wildlife
is very important because they you know
as we saw there with a turtle you can
interact with animals including a manta
ray in our demo that took us down from a
environment that was close to the top of
the water down into the very big depths
of the ocean and that's where I imagine
we're going to start seeing the elements
that really contribute to telling the
story of Abzu because in the beginning
it's it's so ambiguous but there's
clearly something to see and to behold
yeah a lot of different wildlife and we
saw the shot before then and I know by
the end of our demo the shock is is this
like mysterious figure that sort of just
fleet like Flitz in and out of your view
you're trying to chase it trying to see
what is actually happening and I guess
in some of the other trailers that we've
seen for absolute we've seen sort of
much bigger aquatic wildlife like whales
and that sort of thing and even some
mysterious objects in the ocean as well
yeah the trailer from last year showed
this really faint object in the distance
that looks like it could be a large rock
or maybe a large mammal until it until
it becomes just clear enough to see that
no that's a man-made or alien-made ship
of some sort that's really bulbous and
an alien looking and there is this sort
of otherworldly aspect to the real-world
aspects of Abzu I'm super curious as to
what that's going to be and this is this
is a mood game isn't it Peter so it's
not something that you know like an
installable witch or a shooter or
anything like but if you did enjoy you
know something like flower in which you
you know you want to try and explore a
world you know it gets sort of swept in
in in just the mechanics of it and the
music and the mood of it I mean this is
you know like a perfect game in that
style and it was great to play it yeah
I'm very curious about the main
character because you don't at least we
didn't learn anything about who they are
and when you see them from the front of
the mask the the two eyes that the
person has are very clear and the helmet
isn't really shaped like it's supposed
to fit around a human head at least
proportionately to the body so I'm even
wondering if you're human or if you are
some underwater creature yourself it's
or some hybrid thereof I mean it's
really difficult to say at this point
which is weird yet because you know
from talking to the developers they had
modeled the oceans and actual North
Atlantic oceans as well so you know like
for example looking at some really
interesting things yes yeah jellyfish
yeah and then they also had a rock that
looked like it was shaped as a shark as
though that is something that was
created by you know an intelligent being
or you know civilization yeah I think
there's a lot more to explore to this
game and I'm looking forward to when it
comes out in 2016
you